le président gontard moi je n'utiliserai
pas l'euphémisme de madame la présidente
prima j'ai trouvé vos propos absolument
scandaleux scandaleux
j'appelle de mes voeux la proposition du
sénateur gay ne tombez pas dans la
caricature et dans vos propos vous avez
été la carec la caricature même de ce
que vous représentez mais absolue vous
étiez monsieur le président bonta dans
une écologie de l'incantation
c'est à dire il ya qu'à faut qu'on il ya
qu'à faut qu'on
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
d'impasse où il n'y a pas d'alternative
et vous assénez il n'y a qu'à mettre en
place une alternative n'existe pas
monsieur le président que contart
aujourd'hui l'alternative
le deuxième élément monsieur le
président au gothard c est ce que dans
vos propos vous allez dire à tous les
enfants de la république
écoutez au nom de cette écologie de
l'incantation il n'y a pas de problème
dans deux ans vous mangerez du sucre
venant de pays autres européens qui
utilisent ces dérogations ou venant
d'autres pays à l'international mais y'a
pas de problème
écologie de l'incantation et puis le
deuxième élément monsieur le président
vos tard c'est que vous êtes vous êtes
dans une écologie dans une écologie qui
assènent des contrevérités pour pouvoir
mieux appuyer un discours vide
d'arguments les contre vérités que vous
avez utilisé les contre vérités
notamment une une qui me désespère dans
l'entendre dans la bouche d'un
responsable politique aussi cap et que
vous vous avez dit une nouvelle fois il
suffit de mettre en place un plan
d'urgence financier vous le savez
monsieur le président gontard
aujourd'hui les règles européennes
empêche de faire une indemnisation à
100% de nos agriculteurs
vous le savez monsieur prise en compta
ne la semepa c'est une réalité et enfin
monsieur le président gontard l'écologie
d'incantation l'écologie des
contrevérités et puis surtout l'écologie
maintenant de la diffamation finir finir
en disant c'est un texte criminels finir
en m'accusant d'être au lobby de
bailleurs mosanto c'est une écologie de
la diffamation mais sur le président
banda et ça jamais je ne l'accepterai
pas je ne l'accepterai pas moi je suis
un ministre de la république vous n'avez
pas à tenir de tels propos diffamatoires
au titre d'une écologie de ladite
mation ça suffit vous savez lui manque
différentes lois aux différences entre
les agriculteurs et vous monsieur le
président au gothard c'est que les
agriculteurs ils ont le courage de
l'écologie il est écologiste avant même
que vous ne deviez ligne et écologistes
et ils ont le courage de cet écologiste
de cette écologie le courage d'affronter
le temps le courage du réel le courage
d'avoir les pieds les bottes dans la
terre est de savoir comment
l'environnement aujourd'hui il évolue
autour de nous alors stop à cette
écologie de l'incantation et revenait
vraiment dans cette écologie de l'action
et du réel
[Applaudissements]